there were a few rumors after the break
of day came Whispers that were passed on
from the lips of Traitor Caravans as
they traveled from settlement to
settlement not many people would have
believed it way back then it sounded
just like a legend out of an old western
too good to be true a shadowy stranger
wandering the Wasteland riding wrongs
wherever he finds them then when the
job's done and innocent people are safe
once more he walks off into the Horizon
without asking for so much as a thank
you like we said folks would have a hard
time believing such a fanciful tale of
course that was before the sun started
shining an anomalous light over the
world nowadays people might believe
anything the earliest days of this
strange New World proved to be a
learning experience for
scp-4494 otherwise known as the Specter
he was the physical embodiment of the
very notion of fighting crime wherever
Injustice arose he would appear to
Vanquish those that preyed on the
innocent while he usually manifested at
night he never used to have any trouble
appearing in the daytime too in the form
of a shadowy figure wearing a
wide-brimmed hat and a long flowing coat
that he could alter the length of for
added dramatic flourish the specter's
form absorbed almost all the light from
the visible spectrum but after day broke
the rules seemed to have changed one day
the Specter had emerged to find the
sunlight had become unbearable where he
had once been a void of any and all
light he was now finding it impossible
to manifest during daylight the moment
that the unrelenting light from the sun
made contact with him
scp-4494 would dissipate yet he kept
reappearing at night it was like he was
being pulled back into existence and was
only able to re-manifest in the
Moonlight despite it being a reflection
of the anomalous sunlight that was
seemingly enough to negate the effects
it had preventing
scp-4494 from reappearing the same could
not be said for any humans caught in the
white though a far worse fate awaited
them even with much of mankind deformed
into creatures that resembled melted wax
there were still pockets of survivors
and where there were human beings there
would be subsects that wanted to harm or
exploit their fellow man the world might
have no governing bodies anymore no Law
and Order but the Specter had realized
that even in a lawless World his work
was not done as long as there were
survivors of the break of day they still
would need saving not just from the
fleshy hordes of
scp-001-a roaming the wastes but saving
from each other striding through the
remains of the old world in the dead of
night his long cloak billowed out behind
him its shadow almost seemed to blend
with the darkness that surrounded the
Specter but on the horizon the was a
sight he didn't often see these days
light not coming from the sun above nor
the moon but instead it lay ahead of him
a fire glowing not too far away as he
wandered closer Like An Outlaw striding
into town
scp-4494 was presented with the ruins of
a small settlement around him Shacks
burned they're boarded up Windows broken
to allow the cursed sunlight in everyone
that was still alive normally kept
themselves wrapped up head to toe to
block out the Sun but there were clothes
and protective goggles strewn all around
a larger pile of garments fueling a
bonfire
scp-4494 had witnessed the
scp-001-a creatures attacking humans
dragging them out into the light to be
transformed into more anomalous
Abominations but what had happened here
didn't seem to be the work of those
creatures the specters suspicion were
confirmed when he approached the Town
Square to find a group of people who had
all been known into a fleshy Mass the
instance of
scp-001-8 paid the crime fighter little
mind it couldn't move very far the few
vaguely human shapes that protruded out
of it looked like they were Tethered to
poles in the middle of the settlement it
didn't take much longer for scp-4494 to
figure out what had happened here
someone had ransacked the settlement for
some unknown reason maybe they wanted
something maybe they were opportunists
just looking to take advantage of this
new post-apocalyptic world or perhaps
they wanted to be cruel to these
settlers they had broken the barricades
over the windows that blocked out the
sunlight they had trashed the ramshackle
homesteads that these innocent settlers
had been residing in as
scp-4494 looked further there looked to
have been looting too food and water
medical supplies and ammunition not
anything of use to be found all that was
left was what these Raiders hadn't any
need for but as if all that hadn't been
enough as if robbing the settlers For
What Little livelihood they had left
wasn't enough cruelty the bandits had
tethered the survivors to poles in the
center of town they had taken away their
protective gear and left them at the
mercy of the elements and as the sun had
crept higher into the sky and bathed the
captive settlers in its unforgiving
light they had melted into an
scp-001-a creature turning away from the
town the Specter did his best to quell
his rage he wandered in the direction of
the next settlement something was
drawing him there he could feel the pull
of the wrong doers that had left this
Carnage in their wake he would find them
and they would pay for what they had
done there was nothing he could do for
their last victims they had already been
turned by the sunlight but if anyone
could save the next group of survivors
it was him as the wind howled the
shadowy figures cloaked flapped in the
breeze the next settlement looks similar
to the last although still intact Shacks
built from sheets of corrugated iron and
other scrap metal all welded together so
that not even as little as a tiny beam
of sunlight could bleed through as he
stepped toward the boundary of the
settlement a muzzle flashed accompanied
by the deafening echo of a gunshot that
reverberated all around someone had
tried to shoot at the Specter narrowly
missing the bullet whiz past his head
not that it would have harmed him anyway
fear not he declared you can hold your
fire I mean you no harm you are with the
slivers a voice called in the nightly
dark if you mean the evil doers that
left that last settlement over a
smoldering ruin then no I'm not the
Specter replied hearing this he spotted
movement on one of the Shack's rooftops
a sharpshooter carrying a worn old rifle
stood up covered in layers of protection
from the transformative effects of the
Sun's light reflected off the moon Well
you aren't dressed like they are I'll
give you that the Sharpshooter called
can barely make you out wearing all
those dark clothes Mister but if you're
looking to trade I'm afraid your timing
couldn't be much worse tell me reply the
Specter bluntly the criminals that
terrorize the other settlement they've
been here too yes sir the man answered
said they'd be back tonight too I've
come to help to do away with those that
would inflict Justice on the innocent
scp-4494 explained and is typically
dramatic Cadence you call them slivers
yes well they call themselves that the
Sharpshooter said on account of their
choice in outfits they look ridiculous
but they've covered their protective
clothing and slivers of metal and glass
that way they're not only protected from
light but their clothes reflected back
at other people too dastardly villains
taking advantage of what is befall in
the Sun the Specter cursed the bandits
why are they yet to pillage Your
settlement you said they intended to
return well that's what they threatened
earlier a lot of them have been
ransacking any settlement they can shake
they showed up here in their stupid
sparkling outfits and demanded we hand
over a half of all of our food water and
antibiotics they call it their Sunshine
tax according to them if we didn't meet
their demands they'd destroy the town we
didn't know to take them seriously until
we saw the fire over there on the
horizon for a moment the Specter fell
silent his cloak had slowed waving
gently now the winds had died down but
in contrast his anger had never been
higher where are you anyway Mister the
Sharpshooter asked never got your name
my name is the Specter a name these
vagabonds will soon know well for
tonight they will pay the price for
their crimes no offense Mr um Mr Specter
but look around world's gone to hell
ain't no justice anymore what price are
you expecting to make them pay simple
scp-4494 answered the prices they now
have to face me an hour later the
settlement was quiet the Sharpshooter
was still at his post scanning the area
nearby for signs of movement sure enough
he spotted something a group of figures
approaching the Moonlight glinting off
their metallic outfits revealing their
position as they drew closer and closer
to the makeshift town the slivers were
coming but there would be something else
waiting for them when they made their
way into the settlement the other
settlers were awake despite how late it
was wearing their protective layers and
peeking through cracked doors only to
slam them shut as the glimmering gang
crossed the threshold into their
ramshackle home the slivers whooped and
jeered brandishing weapons and
threatening the settlers to show
themselves before the bandits would
break into their shacks and due to them
what they'd done to their neighbors at
the other town but as one of the slivers
approached the door of a shack and began
pounding his boot against the metal door
something reached out of the shadows and
grabbed him in fact it wasn't coming
from the Shadows it was the Shadows this
shrouded in darkness struck the
remorseless Raider even with the
protective layers covering his face the
sliver could feel himself being bruised
by the beating the Specter struck once
more knocking the wrongdoer unconscious
and wrenching the reflective metals from
his outfit shattering them underfoot the
other slivers panicked one drawing a
handgun and firing the shots were
useless all they did was illuminate the
silhouette of a dark cloaked figure
walking closer and closer ready to make
them suffer for their crimes it was dusk
by the time the Specter had beaten the
group of Bandits stripping them of their
distinctive reflective pieces each one
of the slivers had been beaten into
submission suffering broken ribs black
eyes and missing teeth with the danger
over the Sharpshooter and the other
settlers had emerged from their hiding
places all eager to weigh in on how best
to punish the bandits many yelled that
they should be strung up without their
protective gear so that the sun melted
them into an
scp-001-a but the Specter interjected
urging the settlers not to sink to the
level of the criminals they had been
harassed by instead he turned to the
defeated slivers turn over half of your
food water and medical supplies to these
people
scp-4494 demanded in a frighteningly
calm voice then leave walk into these
wastes and don't come back this slivers
agreed and fled running as fast as they
could away from the town why'd you let
them go the Sharpshooter asked these are
uncertain times the Specter replied
noticing the sun was creeping Over the
Horizon it'd be time for him to go soon
in the face of hardship it can be easy
to lose our way justice has always been
blind not blinded by the sunlight But
Blind to prevent bias ah the slivers
might come back though the man said
adding if they can even survive with
what you left him maybe they'll live out
there
scp-4494 responded then again perhaps
not but they have a chance that is
Justice in a time without law it's the
best we can offer and if they carry on
rating folks if they harm others if they
want to waste the chance they've been
given then that is their choice but they
know if they refuse to change then they
will answer to the Specter without the
shadowy crime fighter walked away from
the settlement the unforgiving light of
the sun made him fade as he sauntered
off like an old Gunslinger but he would
be back as long as people needed saving
he would always be back want to own an
SCP of your own go to scpswag.com for
premium anomalous merchandise now go and
check out scp-001 when day breaks and
when day breaks scp-343 for more when
day breaks Tales